[Applaudissements]
ça y est cette fois elle ne changera
plus d'avis Céline Dumerc a décidé de se
retirer des parquets elle l'a fait
savoir avec tout son cœur sur Twitter si
je ne parlais qu'en écoutant mon cœur
l'amour de ce jeu me ferait continuer
jusqu'à l'éternité la gauchère d'un
mètre 69 né à Tarbes est une légende
vivante du basket français cette fois
vainqueur du championnat cette fois
vainqueur de la Coupe de France elle a
tout gagné ou presque une recoupe aussi
un titre de championne d'Europe avec
l'équipe de France et une médaille
d'argent aux Jeux Olympiques de Londres
le 8 avril dernier elle est devenue la
meilleure marqueuse de l'histoire de la
Ligue féminine avec plus de 4600 points
inscrits en carrière
le talent de l'infatigable meuleuse
coriace et visionnaire sur le terrain
avait éclaté au grand jour à Bourges
pierre fausset le président l'avait
choisi pour succéder à une certaine
Yannick Souvré à l'été 2003
Scénic Dumerc restera finalement 11
années à Bourges entrecoupé d'une
expérience à ekaterenbourg et aux
États-Unis
en 2016 elle quitte le Berry et retour
dans le Sud-Ouest pour évoluer sous les
couleurs de basket Land et elle remporte
le championnat à la grande surprise en
2021 et deux Coupes de France dont la
dernière il y a quelques semaines
caps pour y vivre c'est tout dernier et
moi de basket à domicile ce week-end
contre Bourges en quart de finale du
championnat de France et jouer son tout
dernier match quelques jours plus tard
au Prado une sortie plausible avec ses
deux clubs de cœur
[Applaudissements]